j'accueille raphaël mezrahi
dans sa main
sans merci
vous êtes rendu compte à quelle époque
qu'on pouvait être drôle avec un gilet
en laine
je m'en suis jamais rendu compte ouais
non j'avais acheté de mon plein gré au
départ et je suis bien c'est beau ce jeu
fear journaliste et je me suis pour
choix au top et j'étais au top
c'est fou ce j'y vais ce que ça a fait
pour vous qui arrive à c'est vrai mon
brevet ghouma idée ouais non c'était
aussi bien c'est un c'est un beau
souvenir je rappelle ce terrain 1 1
samedi après midi j'étais avec mes
parents puisqu'il tient en faisant les
courses et il s'appelle comment vos
parents lussier des michel c'est joli
voilà on dirait un petit de lelouch
oui ça peut faire des ventes en plus
alors en fait moi j'ai en préparant
cette interview je me suis aperçu qu
avant vos fameuses interviews piéger en
92 vous aviez eu l'idée de créer des
programmes pour pirater antenne 2 à
l'époque voulait mettre un émetteur dans
un semi remorque et faire le tour du
périph pour pas qu'on vous repère oui
une certaine façon il y avait deux
jumeaux vous interprétiez vous
d'ailleurs attiré travaux oui voilà un
et à 3 heures du matin a vu débarquer
chez les gens du bâton de berger
je frappais si j'adore le porte à porte
c'est mon truc dont on rappelle à 3
heures du matin qu'une saucisse à la
main j bonjour au bâton de berger justin
bridou y à pas d'heure pour en manger
comment il a commencé et oui je fais
plein j'ai fait aussi je me suis mis à
poil au bois de boulogne et puis je
tapais contre un arbre pendant deux
heures avec un tahiti douche aussi pour
voir si puis l'a pas plus et après il ya
eu aux fameuses interviews piégé 136
victimes
oui c'est pas rien non non non non non
et puis et puis maintenant les stars
internationales comme les français sont
au courant vous attaquez à brad pitt
george clooney à jennifer lopez britney
spears james brown
ouais bah oui j'ai un grand moment il
est en face de moi comme ça silence de
mort cette bouche de regards depuis j'ai
fait galope
ce qui est incroyable c'est que vous
avez constaté que les stars américaines
en fait elle continue imperturbablement
chat même s'ils s'aperçoivent que c'est
un gag où vous n'êtes pas un vrai
journaliste il continue à faire le
boulot quoi quand ils font leur presse
jon kate bas ils sont professionnels
quoi ils sont tous comme ça en france
c'est vrai qu'ils nous prennent pour des
gabonais en même temps peut-être à cause
de moi on est mal voilà quel art ensuite
vous êtes passé one man show d'abord
avec je m'entraîne avec pierre au début
on est il me dit m'a beaucoup poussé
beaucoup on dit vas-y tu en univers très
particulier
ils vivent il dit moi je l'écoutais au
tout début parce que le premier
spectacle n'était jamais monté sur une
scène je l'appelais je m'entraîne
quand j'ai annoncé la couleur je dis
pourquoi on commence ni votre cote
commencer parlons tracts et la première
semaine j'ai vraiment démarré par un
tacle le rideau sushi bonjour je peux
recommencer donc en tracts et je me
barre je reviens 20 minutes et moi ça me
pose hier à ce que je regarde la traîne
avec dow jones le verbe ou d'en manger
sur un compte séparé très curieux après
je suis parce qu'au point voilà est
maintenant à un match au top je crois
que je tape le spectacle s'appelle je
crois que je suis au top alors il est
question essentielle se souvient la
poussière ah c'est vrai c'est vrai on ne
fait pas de lien social
il y en a partout de la poisse europe si
quand on met du produit anti poussière à
quel moment la poussière le voit
via des mails et rideaux bien que
faisait dieu une semaine avant la
création
ouais dieu seul le sait pourquoi il ya
écrit fin à la fin des films et à jamais
écrit début au début mais demandez à
costa-gavras pas toujours sûr on n'écrit
plus fin
si on exécute un nom c'est fini à vous
la fin alors dans le film la fin les
très surprenante dans le couperet là on
sait pas quoi je veux pas dire si le
parent non la fin est très surprenante
voilà un salaire sur une espèce de point
c'est un polar voilà c'est pas là si on
parlait de moi pour la non seulement on
va parler qua non mais si on va regarder
à quoi ça ressemble tu va regarder ta
caméra et tu vas dire magnéto serge
c'est vrai que le fer ne fait pas va
dans la régie et demande aux mecs